in the streets of new york when you're
coming up what was it like what was it
like trying to make it out of the
streets of new york and making your own
money however
it looked impossible that was gonna
never happen i never even dreamed about
getting out new york i dreamed about
living there
robbing and stealing and dying in the
same block i was born on wow
had no idea this was gonna happen
what changed what i went to a place
called sparta it's like a
correctional center
and my and we watched the movie the
greatest like 78 77 like 11
12.
and they turned on the lights and
muhammad ali came in and for some
strange reasons i want to be like him
as soon as i left it i went to another
place and um
it was a guy that was an xbox and he
told me how to box and that's why i'm
here with you
so before that were you a street fighter
like were you brawler all the time all
the time money yes what does that mean
all the time for money i must have like
three fights four fights a day
for money money i was robbing somebody
yeah walk us through it like your day
was like
walk us through it like are you talking
like kimbo slice like they're fighting
in the streets or just right yeah
so before there was a kimbo you were
fighting in the streets no everyone did
that everyone there was kimbo did that's
what everyone did but they did it
numerous times you did it in this
neighborhood you did it in that
neighborhood and that neighborhood every
night you went through you did it
so you already had a reputation building
the street yes yes and were you a
knockout artist wait yes yes
when when when you were coming up did
you ever like you're talking about 12 13
14 years old fighting
no i'm talking about like from
9 10 11.
[Applause]
by the way just curious he's gonna say
um this stuff is came natural
9 10 11. that's what i was made to do
i'm not going to be
i'm not live i'm like baby huey
so you didn't know your own strength no
now once you realize like you are
stronger than the average human being
you're all of the tough guys and the
criminal guys want to hang out with me
then they put me in that gang now i can
be in that game
they always say get him snatch that
board that's his watch snatch his purse
snatch this snatch that and that's what
our crew was about
did you ever fight somebody that you
were like that they got you was there
ever a kid that got you or not
absolutely
in order to be good you have to lose it
and understand loss because loss is life
was there anyone you fought in the
streets that beat you that later on
became a professional boxer
some of them became drugged us someone
became
um hiding killers that my name but these
guys don't they don't get the
opportunity to get these
blue collar jobs and stuff when you were
coming up at 9 10 11 did you have a
nickname like did they dirty ike dirty
ike yeah
why dirty ike
because even though i had nice clothes
they were always dirty
is that white yes
i had no idea about hygiene i'm nine
years old and i have let's say if i'm
nine years old and i got 5500 bucks on
me i don't know nothing about how i know
to buy the clothes and stuff because i
see my friend and they taught me that
but i go and then i go to my pigeon coop
and i got [ __ ] on the clothes and
everything
i i had no idea about hygiene i just
knew the representation of clothes were
good i didn't know i had to clean them
so let me go back
you just kind of said it very solid any
one of you guys ever at nine years old
had 5 500 bucks in your pocket yeah i'm
90 years old oh um you said you had
fifty five hundred people like raw
people's houses and then people houses
you get everything we had gone now
listen
you have to hear this
since everybody's here you wanna talk
you can't put we robbing these we got
guns we only 10 11 years old we got
automatic guns we got 45.
man it's just crazy
you ain't going in these people
i never knew that i thought you go i
thought everybody house looked like mine
shitty with roaches and all that going
in wow
wow
wow
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]